[Música]
hoy les tengo que contar una historia de
un sueño que se hizo realidad yo me sé
algo 17 años jugando quería necesitaba
hacer un algún negocio para mantenerme
mi mamá me dijo no te voy a seguir
manteniendo no puedo seguir contigo y
tienes que empezar a ganarte la vida de
buscar la manera en la que lo vas a
hacer
fue un parteaguas muy importante en mi
vida pero al final hoy doy este lleva a
más de 4.000 personas
tengo un periódico que es el financiero
en alianza con bloomberg y somos un
referente muy importante en nuestro país
cuando yo era joven adolescente yo no
vengo de una familia
cursos
en enero por herencia sido clase media y
empezando a buscar cómo hacerlo si yo
seguía pensando en alguna estrategia
para poder hacer un negocio y me metí en
un problema en esa edad un amigo me
prestó una moto me la llevo me la roban
y se la tenía que pagar no tenía tan
poco dinero para atrás
entonces vuelvo al problema
logra llegar a un acuerdo con ella
al proyecto el dinero pero me puso a
trabajar aunque yo tenía que hacer
deseables y el dinero
obviamente no era ni siquiera mayor no
podía tener un trabajo formal entonces
ella llamó a uno de sus contactos
conocidos para que de alguna manera ya
llevan un trabajo me empecé a descubrir
a mí mismo que las casualidades se
empiezan a dar y empezó les otras las
casualidades que me robaron la moto mi
madre me puso a trabajar por tres meses
tenía que yo estaba cumpliendo con mi
colegio con tinta abajo para el poder
terminar de pagar cuando termine de
pagar en la moto que fue algo simbólico
me di cuenta que me gustaba trabajar que
era una persona que yo era una persona
que podía servir para algo más
y al darme cuenta que yo voy a servir
para algo más que para estudiar y seguir
haciendo cosas
empecé a buscar de qué manera hacían
negocios
en aquel entonces mi madre me consiguió
trabajo del fisco en una revista
política de nuestro país yo me sé que
hacía todos los mandados y las cosas
factor ya un chofer y muy permiso de
conducción y entonces me dice la gente
oye sabes manejar si me dicen mi jefe de
bossi pero como es que que ya tiene que
ser visto que nos ayudes en la madrugada
a repartir al personal al trabajo atrás
en su casa de regreso yo me di cuenta
que conocía todas las secretarias de las
oficinas de gobierno me conocía a toda
la gente a la que diario le entregaba la
revista porque en aquella época ni
siquiera había internet entonces
yo los veía a diario tienen trato
directo con las secretarias
y yo sabía que había un gran comercio
alrededor de todas las estas oficinas y
secretarias y gentes de intendencia que
vendían cosas entre ellos entonces se me
hizo fácil entrar al centro joyero ver y
comprar joyería por kilos y hace
muestrarios y entonces llevárselos
entonces empecé a ofrecerles joyería a
consignación y después de eso yo les que
me pagaban ni a la quincena y yo pago lo
vio por la mitad el 50 por ciento para
ellos 100% para el primer pago y el
segundo era de entonces
pues lo preguntan un mundo lo importante
de vendedoras y al cabo de un año lo
había juntado en aquella época alrededor
de 50 mil pesos y se encontraba muy
fácil que vendiendo comida podía ser
millonario y va a crecer y va a ser
empresario pero dije en una crisis
siempre la gente como siempre
necesitamos alimentos voy a abrir un
negocio de comida abrió un pequeño local
ikea les cuento que me gasté mil 250 mil
pesos quedó muy bonito local quedó todo
y nos separamos solo
entonces será verdaderamente preocupante
porque yo tenía permiso para pagarle a
dos comidas y todo lo de la historia y
las circunstancias como bailes cambios
los descuentos en la vida se me ocurrió
empezar a ofrecer comidas por siete
pesos a cada uno de los locales que
había alrededor de mi negocio
entonces yo iba a la papelería de los
arroyos de belleza en las transparencias
en las fronteras a las gasolinerías a
todos los negocios alrededor de mi
negocio y por ciento el psoe no les
ofrecía
comidas sustentaba el pago de la renta
del local con mi negocio de joyería per
se estaba acabando el dinero al final
terminé haciendo mínimos comida continuó
con mi nuevo de joyería pero
terminé repartiendo como 120 comidas
diarias repartiéndose hacia mi local no
había negocio pero yo repartía lo que
fuera rentable mi negocio yo te lunes a
viernes
me pasaba trabajando desde la mañana
adaptar hasta la noche muy muy muy duro
porque hacía compras los lunes para
tener comer la comida para toda la
semana y iba a la central de abastos de
su tía tenía todo le llegaba gente
cocinaba yo repartía las comidas y en lo
único que quería hacer era descansar
seguro con frecuentes para huertas
cuando en un momento no porque gracias a
eso nació lo que es contar
gracias a eso es preventivo en el
negocio de las telecomunicaciones y
gracias a eso aprendí a hacer más cosas
en mi vida me llevan a uno de los
empresarios más jóvenes importantes de
mi país
entonces me ocurrió decirle al centro de
dónde reparaban del emisor es que si me
dejaba poner un poquillo una pequeña
cartulina en donde les dijera que
vendían que venía una antena para volver
les dejo ponerlo posibilite left o no yo
seguía entregando las comidas todos los
días
en un día entregándole las comidas que
pregunta este señor oye que tanto sabes
tú de la muerte
y todo esto
para manejar y cambiarle el rangers y
siempre me ha gustado la televisión y
electrónica entonces sabía operada
perfectamente la parabólica y me dice
oyentes de un cliente que le cayó un
rayo en su casa se le dañaron todos los
televisores conocerle daños también el
sistema de la parabólica
podría repararlo vamos a verlo tiene un
tipo completamente diferente a la mía
por lo que llevar los equipos lo que
quería llevárselos a mi casa revisarlos
en la noche que sin tanta presión y que
nadie me viera y entonces regresar y
decirle si se arregla vamos y empiezo a
buscar quién me ayude a repararlo se
encuentra una persona y oye ningún
cliente que tiene una antena parabólica
dañada y que quiero arreglar lo que
podría ser orientar cómo hacerlo yo me
dedico a las antenas parabólicas externo
de vivienda que ahorita no le entiendo
este sistema nuevo que salió hoy listo
ayuda total de que en contra todas estas
personas los negocios con él
y me empieza a enseñar a utilizarlo
y luego van a pedir que lo va a pasar la
reacción a mi cliente si la acepta
dediquen le digo hagan que me había
llevado mi cliente de las comidas que le
dijera su cliente que repararla el andén
a parabólica en las villas que costaba
30 mil pesos 30 mil pesos era lo que yo
soltura va en un mes en mi negocio de
comidas y espantos
y entonces no aceptan el presupuesto
entonces me ayudó a preparar esto de
presupuesto pero en favor de que vengas
conmigo pero yo
entonces no es problema pero lo apagas
total logré hacer
ya en un viaje a estados unidos por unos
receptores y empecé a traer y empezar y
no lo vi uno de los principales
proveedores en todo el país de vender el
sistema de antenas parabólicas
ya sabían demasiado la historia decir
mucho más si estás a tiempo con mi mamá
me quería correr de la casa porque ahora
la persona de servicio por favor por
favor te pido que esto es una empresa
seria en general
este es mi cuarto más dormido hasta las
11 de la mañana
una empresa como el pongo 17 18 años ok
ahora hay que buscar un nuevo tipo pero
no tenía tampoco mucho no hay nada para
moverla es un logotipo que se van a
salir las computadoras que ustedes se
acuerdan de los cursos desde de
microsoft venía un un logotipo de una
parabólica os dije este me lo voy a
jalar y éste es en los tipos de
compensar vamos a poner desplegados en
los periódicos de segunda mano en todos
lados se condensan es una gran compañía
gigantesca que tiene muchos empleados lo
visualizaba
amigos
mil pesos bueno vamos a instalar las
diseña mente entonces empezaba con mis
amigos a instalar las antenas todo y
poco a poco funcionando terreno
se empezó a cavar
y entonces que os voy a hacer ahora me
entiendo que te diga
y aquí ya con las palizas que tenía la
gente que lo había conocido me empecé a
meter en la parte de televisión
profesional y ahora a vender
transmisores para públicas
equipo de edición total empecé a vender
equipo profesional de televisión a poco
tiempo cabo de diez años más o menos con
el señor tumor el 95% de las televisoras
en el país habían sido integradas por
conversar entonces cuando éste se había
vuelto alúmina el indicador pero dicen
tener otro problema ya tenía dinero pero
ya lo tenía marcado porque no se hacían
diarias televisoras entonces yo tenía
que buscar ahora con nueva solución que
me llevara a seguir creciendo por 2
2 de abril oficinas en centroamérica
estaba creciendo y empezamos a aceptarlo
centroamérica hicimos un durante h
hicimos muchas muchas más instalaciones
y empezamos a crecer en diferentes
países en latinoamérica hasta llegar a
verse
y empezamos a aprender que amarás a los
bancos a las industrias
a las ciudades se hagan muchas cosas
vamos a vender cámaras de circuito
cerrado de televisión y entonces como
que sean precios ramas de servicios pero
que quería yo y funcionar en los medios
de telecomunicaciones porque yo decía a
ver cómo es posible encontrar hacemos
todo esto
estamos atrás de la información de los
medios pero no participamos de manera
activa
bueno un periódico
entonces total empezó a buscar carrizal
de periódicos y me encuentro con que el
periódico en financiero
que tenía una excelente excelente
reputación no será una gran oportunidad
porque su fundador había fallecido logró
contactar con la familia cárdenas le
dijo
yo me dedico a la televisión y total de
que decida venderme
y les quiero decir que en los últimos 50
años en nuestro país va la transacción
más importante que existe un medio de
comunicación
control periódico financiero yo no sé
nada de los periódicos solo también de
nada me acuerdo de repartido revistas y
de ahí inició todo esto y gracias a
costa ya que yo me había dado dinero
para comprarlo con una comunicación en
posición de algún presidente y director
general del periódico el financiero no
tenía ni idea de cómo operar un
periódico
total de que empiezo a viajar alrededor
del mundo y en uno de estos viajes a los
principales diarios más importantes
en diferentes partes del mundo nueva
york
esto obviamente jordan que tienen
y tecnológicamente se dedicaba a lo
mismo que yo a lo mismo que yo y cuando
identificado de una visita de dos
minutos para enseñar quiero conocer a
este señor mike bloomberg
sí pero él no atiende gente es el mejor
de nueva york ahora y ya no está
llevando bien
usted tiene que hablar yo quiero traer a
bloomberg
bueno al cabo de tres semanas
le estaba proponiendo que me diera que
me diera por favor la oportunidad de
poner mi periódico en su plataforma y
que su plataforma de socios es uno de
los millones del mundo entonces llegamos
a un acuerdo y hoy el financiero
bloomberg es una plataforma más de las
más importantes en nuestro país y
entonces
esta es la historia que me han llevado a
todos los casos en los cuales mi mamá
y hoy le doy las gracias mi mamá porque
me enseñó a aplicar algo que yo no sabía
de mí
y me da igual éxito hoy está cumplido
condensado en el mundo de las
telecomunicaciones
somos líderes lo que hacemos
tenemos la plataforma del técnico
financiero y como les comenté al
principio de mi plática hoy damos empleo
a más de 4.000 personas
todo esto nos lleva a decirles que si
persiguen sus sueños se pueden hacer
realidad hoy mismo
[Aplausos]